won't like me when I'm angry
a Brazilian bodybuilder has been hailed
as the real-life Hulk boasting
incredible 63 centimeter biceps
unfortunately Romario Alves is striking
muscles weren't just the product of
bench pressing instead the man turned to
a lethal cocktail of oil and alcohol
injections called synthol to enhance his
arms after three years of habitual use
Romero's addiction turned deadly the
injections caused a buildup of rocks
yes rocks inside his arms while toxins
in the oil began to trigger kidney
failure doctors originally threatened to
amputate both arms but they were able to
remove the synthol rocks and he made a
full recovery
Romario hopes his story brings awareness
to other athletes who are curious about
performance-enhancing drugs all right so
we're gonna link to more about the story
right down below and in it it's actually
pretty depressing like he ended up
trying to commit suicide he was in
depression for a long time clearly like
some sort of body dysmorphia yeah and
all that stuff look off my face I'm just
like I can't yeah go take it right now I
just don't like muscles anyway yes so
that was a lot for me like a little bits
okay look enough like you know lift a
bag but like past that no gross yeah
what kind of gay are you
gays are obsessed with what is not true
and you know that's not true
I live in West Hollywood these people I
live in those feelings I'm fine no see
that's that's what I should probably be
lazy yeah I mean this is actually kind
of a sad state I mean he was his wife
was pregnant you tried to commit suicide
during that time I mean he was about to
have the thing he worked so hard for
maybe didn't work hard for it all but
we're about to be amputated I'm like is
he was he did he have strength with this
product or is it just producing like
that's also working out though so I
think he probably had muscles that were
just kind of bigger looking here's the
thing that I'm wondering about and I
know that with your extensive medical
background yes when these when these
rocks are forming doesn't it in turn
kind of constrict his actual muscle mass
of like the ability to grow yes well as
a doctor I can confirm that it right yes
obviously when you have giant arms like
this like you wouldn't be able to
do certain things but I always think
this when I see these guys with huge
muscles in West Hollywood I'm like you
guys don't look like you can move really
so like you even throw a ball like yeah
crazy about like practical uses aside
from Simon can you imagine having sex
with them no I'm saying like like what
do you hold on to you well you can hold
on to those two nodules those things
there's not even a muscle where that
that's not like no I don't yeah yeah but
they are like little handles no
suppressing other stories that they call
him the real-life Hulk he's not even
green so what's the goddamn point if
you're ready check yourself with
something at least include some food
some food dyes so they don't have like a
full experience well how much do you
think has to do with just like the state
of Technology we live in where
everything looks better on and everyone
wants to show off constantly on
Instagram and Twitter and Facebook and
like you filter things and you
manipulate things and you take 18
selfies so you always look great so
everyone always looking at things that
look better than actual I think you
could totally talk about like how that
affects body dysmorphia and like
anorexia and bulimia and also eating
disorders but this guy in particular I
feel like there's not so much about
Instagram and more about like that
particular lifestyle well yeah I don't
know maybe I don't fall enough muscle
people on Instagram but I feel like
that's kind of its own thing yeah I
think there's there is like it within
that community like it's not to get
bigger and and just bigger
yeah how much for you like that that
social media party but you're a public
person like people are coming to
yourself to see you like that everyone
you can manipulate every image about you
like it definitely affects how we all
act right I'm horrible with posting
pictures of myself because I actually I
have no shame or filter like I'm not one
for filtering out or smoothing things I
should the other day I posted a video of
myself literally looking like a potato
like my facebook like a potato and I
didn't care if errantly because you know
I screw it I just woken up I think and
you know it feels good cuz it's like I
feel like people can maybe relate to me
more that's what I'm telling myself to
feel better about the situation are you
okay looking like a potato let us know
in the comments right now